CHET HAASE: Donuts and coffee.
So we wanted to give this
talk because we like talking
about donuts and coffee.
More specifically, we're going
to talk about self-publishing,
if anyone's curious about
that, and talk about the books
that we self-published
in particular.
The process of self-publishing,
the pain and turmoil
of doing e-publishing.
And we were thinking
that we would call
it self-publishing for fun.
Profit doesn't
really enter into it
unless you pursue it a
lot harder than we do.
ALON HALEVY: Or if you daydream.
CHET HAASE: Yeah.
I daydreamed when I
originally published,
of actually making
money at it, and then I
realized that if you don't
actually market your book,
it doesn't magically
happen somehow.
Things don't go viral
on their own it--
ALON HALEVY: [INAUDIBLE].
CHET HAASE: --turns out.
So there's alternative
titles that we
thought of for the
presentation, how
to turn $20,000 into a
warehouse full of books.
That was your personal
experience I believe.
ALON HALEVY: It was
a bit more than that.
CHET HAASE: Excellent.
AUDIENCE: What was the dollars?
ALON HALEVY: More than $20,000.
CHET HAASE: But you didn't need
that money for anything anyway.
Also, writing is the easy part.
Turns out the process
of actually publishing,
especially all the
follow-on things
like do you want to get it
in that store, in this thing,
in the marketing thing we
haven't completely figured out.
Those are all real work.
The writing's just the fun part
that you do at the beginning.
And also, who says you need
marketing to sell products,
and it turns out
that we say that.
ALON HALEVY: We will say that.
CHET HAASE: And I
had nothing better
to do with my weekends
and all of that spare time
that I spent actually whipping
these things into shape to do
this.
ALON HALEVY: I thought
you work on Android.
Do you have weekends?
CHET HAASE: No comment.
I thought that it would
be appropriate to start
with a reading.
ALON HALEVY: Do you want to--
CHET HAASE: If I may.
This is going to
be somewhat solemn,
but we'll see how this goes.
"Donut and coffee,
together again.
I haven't had these two
since I don't know when.
But wait, just last
Friday before the weekend
I had three or
four or five then."
I don't know why this is here.
ALON HALEVY: OK, this
is my introduction.
So Chet is too humble,
way too humble.
And this is my excuse,
this is my explanation
for why he's going to be funnier
than me during this talk.
So he is actually the official
winner of the unofficial title
of the funniest man
in Silicon Valley,
and I believe he got this
through an official/unofficial
competition.
CHET HAASE: Yeah, it's what some
of these people actually saw.
ALON HALEVY: So you know
what we're talking about.
CHET HAASE: Yes.
So-- There's no pressure.
ALON HALEVY: No pressure on me.
CHET HAASE: I'm just
shifting blame, as it were.
So we were going to talk
about various phases-- hey,
look at that!
Let's talk about our books.
Why don't you add a slide
about your books here?
[LAUGHTER]
So I want to write
a book about coffee.
I wrote three
comedy books so far,
mostly the one
about donuts today.
There's various stages in the
process of actually developing
the idea and writing this
thing, and then figuring out
how to publish it, and then
figure out e-publishing,
so we're going to sort
of walk through these
and compare and contrast.
We went different routes.
I do think that it's
interesting to look
at the-- do a high
design thing and then do
a pre-buy of a bunch
of books route,
versus the print on demand,
which makes this much more
approachable and
cheap for people that
don't have more than $20,000
to populate a storage
thing with books.
ALON HALEVY: It's in
the USA, Kentucky.
OK.
CHET HAASE: OK, well,
it's cheaper there.
So go.
ALON HALEVY: OK.
So my book is "The Infinite
Emotions of Coffee."
it's sitting there on the table.
It's a book about
coffee and culture.
So the reason I
wrote this book was I
realized that everywhere
I travel in the world,
I get different cultural
experiences when
I go to different cafes.
And so I figured nobody-- I
couldn't figure out anybody
who wrote a book about this.
I figured somebody has
to do it, so I did it.
I traveled to
about 30 countries.
I talked to farmers,
roasters, baristas,
all kinds of eclectic people
in the coffee industry.
I drank a lot of
coffee-- a lot of coffee.
I can now drink 10 cups
of coffee within a day
and not have my head explode.
And this is the
result of the book.
I mean this is the result.
And if you don't
believe me, you want
to believe Vint Cerf, the
inventor of the internet,
who I want to say reached
out to me to have his quote
on the back of the book.
It's not exactly
the way it went.
CHET HAASE: Go ahead
and say it anyway.
He's not here.
ALON HALEVY: He was involved.
For those of you who
are not caffeinated up,
I'll read this out. "The
histories of communication--"
Get it?
Communication.
Internet.
Vint Cerf.
"And coffee's impact
on socialization
are interconnected.
From the combined perspectives
of a computer scientist--"
That's me.
"And the coffee culturalist--"
I guess that's me too.
"This book elucidates--"
this is really funny.
[LAUGHTER]
CHET HAASE: Never
read this before.
ALON HALEVY: "How
coffee conversations
have evolved from the
age of exploration
that characterize
the 15th century--"
CHET HAASE: "Through
the 15th century,
through the
Information Age where
the Internet
spheres of influence
in the world of
coffee continue--"
ALON HALEVY: "To expand."
CHET HAASE: --"to expand."
It's beautiful.
That's beautiful.
Did he know that he wrote that?
Did he actually just
have someone who
works for him write this thing?
Or was it just like
algorithmically
generated on some [INAUDIBLE]?
ALON HALEVY: It's actually
more complicated than that.
But I'm not sure I
should go into it.
He said yes.
[LAUGHTER]
CHET HAASE: From one of the
programming books that I
did when we wrote
about Java and Swing,
we got James Gosling to
agree to do a forward to it,
which if you're going to publish
a Java book is pretty huge.
That was fantastic.
Except for the part where
he never actually did it,
and we got down to like,
well, the publisher's
going to actually print
the books tomorrow,
so it's too late.
We'll have somebody else,
like my dog, write something,
and I said, thanks, James,
but we really need to move on.
And then he quickly
sent me something
that was clear that it
would work for the book
and that he hadn't actually
read any page of the book.
Had no idea what it
was, but it didn't
matter because we got James
Gosling's name on the book
cover.
ALON HALEVY: That really
generated a lot of--
CHET HAASE: I don't really know.
I'm still getting
royalties from a book
on an obsolete technology
that's eight years old.
So maybe that's due to him?
So the book that I wrote
was "Round and Holy."
It's poems, and they
actually manage to rhyme,
and they're about donuts,
because, you know, why not?
I also brought in an illustrator
friend of mine, an artist
that I knew for
years and years and I
love his sort of
black sense of humor.
And I thought wouldn't
it be fun to actually do
a project with someone else.
So instead of just me
doing words, words, words,
I brought this friend in.
He came in for the weekend, we
just sort of jammed on ideas,
and he did a bunch of
pictures for the book.
So this was a departure
from my previous books
where it was basically just
like me wrapping up stuff
that I posted on
my blog or wherever
and putting it out
as fast as I can.
This one was collecting the
words and sort of designing it
around the pictures that sort of
illustrated what was going on,
because I think there's nothing
more tedious than a poetry
book that's just words.
So we thought maybe it
would be a little more fun
if it actually had pictures
to go along with the words.
I wanted to break
here and do a--
ALON HALEVY: I hope
this one will be more
upbeat than the previous poem.
CHET HAASE: It's poetry.
Poetry's not meant to be
upbeat or very serious.
"The problem's not
solved by a donut or few,
and even those problems
are solved by two."
[LAUGHTER]
So we have a little bit of
background in real publishing
as well.
This fed into, well, could
we do a book on something
that we're actually
interested by instead?
So years ago, I wrote this
Swing book, a programming
book [INAUDIBLE], and I
spent six or nine months sort
of writing and editing,
and editing, and editing,
and editing, and
editing, and finally they
published the thing.
It's actually still selling.
I don't know who
is buying a book
in this obsolete technology.
I followed that up about
four years later by a book
on Flex, which seemed like a
really good idea at the time,
and then the platform
died within about a year.
Not a lot of people
buying that book.
These were both a
whole lot of work--
we were working with
real publishers.
To a great extent, "Flex 4
Fun" was a smaller publisher,
but there was real
editors working
on this thing in
these specific formats
that they needed
you do things in.
This is in direct
opposition to the process
that I used for the books
that I self-published.
ALON HALEVY: Yeah.
So I wrote actually in
parallel with the coffee book.
I wrote a book about
data integration.
You'll see it over
there on the left
with two of my former Ph.D.
students, which didn't make it
less work than
writing it on my own.
Yeah, this was published
by Morgan Kaufmann I think.
Is that the MK on the cover?
CHET HAASE: Sure.
Yeah.
ALON HALEVY: It took
about five years.
550 pages of--
CHET HAASE: Words.
ALON HALEVY: --words.
Theorems, too.
CHET HAASE: Yeah.
Equations.
Yeah, if anybody wants to
write a technical book,
I would suggest you
don't, unless you really,
really want to spend a long
time with that technology
and not actually get much
out of it in the end.
People will buy these things.
There's a little
more discrete thing
they are purchasing than the
random interest topic that
gets you to write the coffee
book or the humor book
or whatever.
But the amount of effort you
put into programming books
right now compared to the
number of people that buy books
specifically, that market
basically evaporated
around the year 2000.
People look out on Stack
Overflow and copy and paste
stuff.
They look for free
content on blogs
and wherever they can find it.
And they're not really
turning to books anymore.
So they still exist.
People will still pick
up books occasionally,
but it's sort of depressing
to put that much of your life
into projects right now just to
have not many people actually
pick them up.
So I've been planning to write
an Android book for years now
and I haven't--
ALON HALEVY: It won't happen.
CHET HAASE: --because of that.
What's that?
ALON HALEVY: You don't
want to kill Android.
[LAUGHTER]
CHET HAASE: It was pointed out
that both of these platforms
did actually start a steep
decline after our books came
out.
ALON HALEVY: So actually
with data integration
that's not the case.
Data integration--
CHET HAASE: It's still new data.
ALON HALEVY: Data
integration is guaranteed
to be a problem
that will interest
about 17 people in the world
at any given point in time
for the foreseeable future.
And there's no other book
about it, guaranteed.
CHET HAASE: So people could
write other books on data for--
ALON HALEVY: No.
Yeah, other books on data,
but not data integration.
You don't want to
compete with that.
CHET HAASE: No.
No.
ALON HALEVY: No.
CHET HAASE: OK, so the big
ideas behind the books.
ALON HALEVY: Big idea?
CHET HAASE: Do you
have to big idea?
ALON HALEVY: Did you meant--
Did you say something about--
Did we have to have a
big idea to come here?
CHET HAASE: Make one up now.
Go.
ALON HALEVY: A big idea.
Wow.
OK.
How big does it have to be?
CHET HAASE: Medium.
ALON HALEVY: So my idea
was to travel the world.
So I was doing a lot of
traveling even before I start
writing this book because I do
a lot of-- I give a lot of talks
all over the world,
so I go places,
and I realized that
everywhere I go,
I actually go and sit
in cafes because that's
where I get to see
the people, I get
to try the different Wi-Fi
networks and stuff like that.
And so that's how I started.
And then the idea
of the book was
to actually explore that at
scale, because everything
we do at Google we do at scale.
So scale doesn't
just come like that.
It's actually hard work.
So this is an example of--
this is an Irish coffee which
is a combination of
espresso, cream, and whiskey.
This is made by an Icelandic--
the Icelandic Irish coffee
champion who--
CHET HAASE: I didn't
know that was a thing.
OK.
All right, there's
categories for everything.
Great.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHET HAASE: What's that?
AUDIENCE: The funniest
man in Silicon Valley.
CHET HAASE: Yes.
Exactly.
Thanks.
ALON HALEVY: You have to be a
little bit more open-minded.
You can't just be funny.
This guy's very serious.
So this is an interesting
story, because I
went to the world barista
championship, which
is an event that
happens every year.
And this guy's daughter was
the Icelandic barista champion.
His son was the Icelandic
coffee tasting champion,
which is-- there's a
competition on that.
And so he felt he needed
to do something in order
to hang out with his children.
And so he saw there
was an opening
to compete for the Icelandic
Irish coffee championship--
CHET HAASE: And it turns out
he was the only contestant.
ALON HALEVY: Actually no.
He was one of six, so he made
it to the finals by default.
But then he won and he actually
did better than his kids
in the world championship.
He scored eighth in the world.
And so I came to him-- and
this was in London in the world
championship-- and
I said, you know,
I need to write about
you guys in my book
because you make a great story.
So he said, well, why don't
you come visit us in Iceland?
And I was like, OK.
So I bought a ticket to
Iceland and the weekend
after I was in Iceland in
this little town called
Selfoss, Iceland, which is
mostly known for the place
where Bobby Fischer the
famous chess player died.
CHET HAASE: OK.
ALON HALEVY: So there I was in
a little house-- their summer
house-- and he was making
Irish coffee for everybody.
And this is my big idea.
I have more.
So then I went-- this
is an exploration.
This is in Ethiopia, the
birthplace of coffee,
where I had to see
the real growers.
This is interesting.
So what these guys are doing
is they're smoking khat.
Khat is a plant that is
a competitor to coffee
in the sense that it's easier
to grow multiple times a year.
And if you chew enough
of it, you get stoned.
And so the value
proposition was much higher.
In fact, most people--
the Yemenite economy
was basically ruined
because people
are smoking khat all day.
So I wanted a picture
of people smoking khat
in Ethiopia, so I
actually hired these guys
to sit there and chew this
thing for an hour, which was not
hard to convince them to do.
And this the photo.
This is my big idea.
CHET HAASE: The
actor is from LA.
Hired them-- flew
them to Ethiopia.
ALON HALEVY: No, I
couldn't afford that.
And there's a long story
about why I got to Bosnia
as part of my research.
I'll skip that.
CHET HAASE: OK.
ALON HALEVY: Because
we only have one hour.
CHET HAASE: Yes.
ALON HALEVY: But as you can
see, this woman is Laila.
She's a friend of a
friend of a friend who
I met through a
person who argued
that I should go to Bosnia
to try out the coffee there.
So what I did was the way I
got into the coffee industry
was I bribed people.
I would buy them Google--
CHET HAASE: Cake.
ALON HALEVY: No.
Hats and sweaters and t-shirts.
At certain points, coffee
people would get together
and they would see
that they each had
a Google shirt or something and
they would form the connection.
This was her birthday.
Her mom baked her a Google
cake because my visit there
was such a big event.
Anyway, that's my big idea.
CHET HAASE: All right.
ALON HALEVY: Now you
follow that [INAUDIBLE].
CHET HAASE: I have huge ideas.
So my ideas behind
the poetry book
were that I really liked donuts.
Every Friday we bring in donuts.
There's a little donut club.
People bring in donuts
and we eat them,
and it's a fantastic tradition.
I like them actually a lot,
and I also like writing a lot.
I like to think about funny
writing, clever writing, word
play, all of that stuff.
And it dawned on
me at some point
a few years ago that poems
are like word puzzles,
and I happen to
like puzzles a lot.
But you take the genesis
of an idea-- sometimes
it's an image that you have
that you'd like to convey.
A lot of times it's a meter.
I will have a phrase, a
sentence that occurs to me
and I really like the
meter of that sentence
and I'd like to express
an idea around it.
So it usually starts from
that one little nugget
and then I build
something around it.
The puzzle is how can you get a
rhyme scheme and a meter scheme
to work and still get that
same idea across and remain
consistent and hold
to the original idea.
And can you throw in other
things along the way,
like word plays,
and get the word
plays to occur at the right
time, at the end of a verse
or whatever.
And so I like all the mechanics
of actually putting the poems
together so that they pull all
of these elements together.
So the idea for the coffee
book began all over the world,
apparently.
ALON HALEVY: Yes.
So I was trying out Google
Maps and I made a plan,
this is my plan.
I put a green
thingamajig, marker,
everywhere I felt like
I needed to go in order
to fully understand the vast
majority of the coffee world.
And I start executing.
CHET HAASE: I should
have had a map for mine
that would have just had a
green marker in Pleasanton.
ALON HALEVY: Yeah.
So the process.
So what I did was I
researched, I went somewhere,
I met with people,
I learned stuff,
and then I started writing.
So I started in Google Docs
because that was the simplest
thing.
I realized Google
Docs really sucks.
Sorry-- this is being recorded.
At the time, when
it started-- it
was the initial
days of Google Docs,
and it wasn't up to the
level that it is today.
I would say also it is
not a publishing platform.
It is a convenient way to
record basic text stuff
and you've got to do
some basic formatting,
but actually doing a
book in there I think
is beyond the scope.
ALON HALEVY: Yeah.
So then I would start.
I would think maybe I can
do it in Word because I can
do a little formatting there.
I gave up on that really quickly
because Word is really bad.
And the engineer in me, or the
academic in me tried LaTeX.
Have you heard of LaTeX?
CHET HAASE: Uh-huh.
Uh-huh.
ALON HALEVY: Because
in LaTeX, you
can actually get anything done.
But then I thought that
maybe down the line
if I work with a publisher or
someone who will do my design,
they might not know LaTeX.
CHET HAASE: You think?
ALON HALEVY: I wasn't sure.
So then you write
and you rewrite.
After a while I got
very good at this.
So I would do my research
and I would start actually
writing the chapter on
a particular destination
before I left, so that
way the questions that I
had when I got to the
destination were much clearer.
So I didn't have any
preconceived ideas yet.
But then I would write,
and then I would travel,
and then I would rewrite,
and that worked out better.
So now if you ask me to
write about some coffee
region in the world, I'm a lean,
mean coffee writing machine.
AUDIENCE: What did you
write at him at the end?
ALON HALEVY: In the end-- Huh?
CHET HAASE: Was it in design?
ALON HALEVY: Yes.
So in the end I gave all
the text to the designer
and I told her to
do the best she can.
The book is actually--
if I may say
so myself because I didn't
do the design-- is beautiful.
CHET HAASE: It's true.
It's slightly higher
designs than mine.
I used a different process.
The donut book actually
started with two previous books
that I had.
I had written a series
of essays on my blog
called "When I Am King--"
these silly ideas that I had.
And eventually I wrapped
up a bunch of these
into the book strangely
titled, "When I Am King."
I wrapped them up.
I collected them all and
then I self-published this.
I used-- Did I talk
about Word there.
I used Word.
I did not have that
problem with it.
I have various
problems with Word,
but it did accomplish
what I needed it to.
The images-- moving
things around in Word
gets a little bit
funky, but it does
allow you to stylize the
text and the chapters
and the headings
and stuff like that.
You can have footnotes.
You can do the basic publishing
stuff that you certainly
could not do in Docs.
So that was good enough for me.
Certainly sitting
on my own and--
ALON HALEVY: Well,
maybe when you
do this there wasn't Docs yet.
CHET HAASE: I guess
that might be the case.
But I wouldn't use it
now either because I
depend on these things
to sort of put it
in book form, which is quite
different than online form.
And then I kept writing these
silly essays on my blog.
Eventually I wrote this second
book, I wrapped things up.
I spent a little bit more time
sort of designing and putting
this thing together, but again,
using Word to do all the stuff.
And then eventually
I started eating
a lot of donuts on Friday
and writing poems and odes
to those donuts because.
And then I convinced this
artist friend of mine
to actually fly
out to California
and do some pictures.
And I kept trying
to tell him, Mark, I
gotta make money on this thing.
And he came anyway,
so that was great.
One of the ideas that
I wanted to pursue here
was that I was very successful
at publishing comedy books that
didn't sell very well.
And I thought if there's
any book in the world that
doesn't sell well, it's
a slim volume of poetry.
So if I want the best
non-selling book in the world,
clearly I needed to
publish some poetry.
So that's what I did.
So now there's a
slim volume of poetry
that even more people can't buy.
So why--
ALON HALEVY: I
actually-- So Chet
is talking a lot about
donuts and he probably
feels guilty for talking
so much about donuts.
CHET HAASE: Why?
ALON HALEVY: No.
Maybe he's not.
The interesting story behind
all of this, the reason why
this talk is happening
is because the two of us
actually met at the gym.
OK, so we actually work out
at the gym at the same hour
Monday, Wednesday,
Friday with George.
And we realized both of us
have very similar experience
about books that haven't quite
hit the top, the "New York
Times" bestsellers yet, but
there's still room to grow.
So it's not like we just
eat donuts all the time.
We actually work out.
CHET HAASE: Because we
eat donuts all the time.
[LAUGHTER]
So one engenders the other.
ALON HALEVY: Yeah.
CHET HAASE: I would
like to point out, too,
I have another book
that I haven't talked
about today, which is a
number one "New York Times"
national bestseller.
That's the working title,
but it's still in progress.
ALON HALEVY: OK, so now it's
like-- Oh, so publishing.
So I did spend some
time trying to find
a publisher for
my book, thinking
coffee is a topic
that should interest
at least a billion people.
And even if we get a
small chunk of that,
the publishers will be happy.
So I talked to a
bunch of publishers.
I even got an agent at some
point, like in New York City,
67th floor, on a street
with a number, an avenue
with a number in New York.
But then some of the
publishers, they really
looked deeply at the book.
And they basically
said, I've looked
at your CV and your book.
And they suggested very
kindly, very constructively,
that maybe I instead write
a book about big data.
Which was a compliment.
At least they thought
I know something
about big data, which is nice.
And since I was
already doing that,
I didn't think I want
to write another one.
The other thing about
the publisher side,
at some point I realized
that whatever publisher
I get either wouldn't be very
effective in terms of-- I
mean you could always get
a second rate publisher.
Well, third rate-- but they
wouldn't provide much value,
and they would take more
control than I wanted.
And I wanted complete
control over this book,
which I didn't want to give up.
CHET HAASE: On my side, I
heard this awesome quote.
I was reading online
because a few years ago
I thought wouldn't it be
cool if I could actually
sell some books.
And somebody asked
a famous agent
that sells things
like comedy books,
they said, well, how would an
author get published and sell
books?
And the answer was be famous.
Apparently that is the strategy.
If you're selling something,
especially something
as nebulous as humor,
the only reason
that people will pick it
up is because maybe it
strikes a particular
nerve, but more probably
because they know that person.
They know that Tina
Fey is very funny
and so they will
pick up her book.
It turns out to be
a fantastic book,
but they probably wouldn't
have bought an autobiography
by someone they hadn't
heard of before.
Similarly, they're
probably not going
to buy a book on
someone that wants
to become king if they haven't
heard of that person before.
So it turns out that I don't
really have that going for me.
So yeah, what do you get when
you take an unknown author
an idea for a humor book
and queries the publishers
and agents.
And the answer is nothing.
You get nothing whatsoever.
So I'd send out
queries occasionally,
I'd get no response.
Or I would talk to my publisher
of my programming books
and say, hey,
you're a publisher.
You must know about this thing.
What I really want to
write is-- and again, I
would get no response.
They'd just be flummoxed
by the question.
Like I publish
programming books.
I really don't know how to
deal with your pet project.
So at that point
of life, well, I
was really interested in
publishing my own thing
and it didn't really matter,
fortunately that I didn't
have a publisher because all
of a sudden print on demand
and self-publishing became
a real thing a few years ago
where anybody could
start to do this.
ALON HALEVY: I want to
point out, actually,
publishers who don't publish
your books come into two types.
Those who will waste a
huge amount of your time
and not publish.
And those who will tell
you right off the bat, no.
OK?
I had both kinds.
CHET HAASE: I just had
the single kind that
didn't actually get back to me.
ALON HALEVY:
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
They still waste your
time, because you
need to write a nice email.
CHET HAASE: It also takes
a fair amount of homework
even to reach those
people, to figure out
who they are to send
the query letters,
to actually try to get
in touch with them.
I have a friend who came, he's
a refugee from the publishing
industry, and he
suggested that you never
use a publisher anymore, because
a lot of what they're doing
is actually busy work.
They are sending
out press releases,
they're sending out
letters, they're sending out
information that
goes into the rags
to get the reviews at
the right time year,
they're distributing the books,
they're getting the books back.
It's basically the grunt
work of simply pushing
letters and communication
and books around.
And he thought
it's much better--
and then in the
meantime, they take
95% of the revenue
from the book,
and then the author
is left with not much.
Which I agree with that.
On the other hand, I don't
want to do the grunt work.
Wouldn't it be nice if
someone else did it instead.
Formatting.
So the nitty-gritty of
actually writing this thing.
ALON HALEVY: Yes.
So after I finished writing
and rewriting and rewriting,
I found a designer through a
connection in coffee industry.
Somebody who had actually
worked on "Barista" magazine,
the shirt that I'm wearing.
So she actually had a lot of
connections in the industry
and she was able to find
photos that I didn't have.
She actually had a
passion for coffee,
which is really good if you're
formatting a book about coffee.
She lives in Portland,
so she was pretty cheap.
Got it?
She lives in Portland
so she was unexpensive.
CHET HAASE: OK.
ALON HALEVY: So
anyway, $3,500 got
me the whole design of the
book, which could be considered
the highlight of the process.
She was in design.
CHET HAASE: I did not pay.
Instead I used Microsoft Word.
Styles are very helpful.
You can say this is the
title, this is a verse,
and it sort of automatically
formats a bunch of stuff.
And then you sort of dork around
moving images, stuff like that,
but fairly straightforward.
There are templates
available from publishers.
So I published-- all
three of my books
right now are going
through CreateSpace,
which is owned by Amazon.
And they had
templates for things
like the interior
and the cover, so you
can say here's how
big my book is,
and they'll give you a
template for a cover that
matches that spine
size, as well as
the overall format of the book.
And same thing for the interior.
The donut book happens
to be a four by five,
and they have templates that
you can customize for that,
and then suck them
right into Word
and get the basics
of that going.
So it didn't cost me anything
to format the entire book
by myself.
Arguably, it is not as
pretty as the coffee book.
And also it tends to take a lot
of time sort of futzing around
with Word to sort of
shoehorn it into the place
you want it to be with
the various styles.
And then you change
things around
and that sort of normal thing.
So a little bit more work for
doing everything on your own,
obviously.
Self-publishing process.
This is where it
gets interesting.
The sort of do you
print ahead of time
or do you do print on demand.
ALON HALEVY: Right.
So I was imagining sales
of many millions of copies.
So I had to print ahead of time.
So I found a publishing
house in Kentucky.
OK, this was at the time where
doing anything in the USA
was considered patriotic.
I could have done
it cheaper in China,
but then the
shipping costs would
have outweighed the benefit,
so I didn't do that.
I may have printed
a bit too many.
For some unclear
reasons, the contract
with the guys in Kentucky are
such that they don't charge me
for storing books, unless they
will tell me years later which
they haven't yet.
So it working out pretty well.
Whenever Amazon makes an
order I send them the order
and they send it to Amazon.
And every now and then
I'll replenish my garage,
and it works out nicely.
I contributed to their Christmas
fund, and their Easter fund,
and another Christmas fund.
I'm doing good for Kentucky.
CHET HAASE: The print on demand
model is quite a bit different.
The best thing
about it, and this
is the reason why I would
say everybody can consider
doing this if they want
to actually sort of have
a publishing project, is
there's nothing that you pay.
All you pay is your time.
So as long as you have the
software that you need,
you can write it in
whatever you want.
You upload it in PDF format.
So there was only the cost
of the computer resources
and the software
that I was using,
and then my time to actually
write and format this thing.
The way the money works
out in print in demand,
it's built into the sale.
So you tell them how much you
want to charge for the book
and it has to be
above some minimum
so that they can make the
raw cost from printing
the book back.
So then they get
their raw cost back,
plus some percentage
of the rest,
and then you get the
royalties that are left.
So the more you
charge for the book
the higher your royalties
are going to be,
and the more you're
going to scare away
your potential customers.
So the first time I
tried this Lulu.com
had a lot of good press,
so I went with them.
It turns out they're
quite expensive.
It was slightly higher
quality I thought
on the cover and the paper.
But I ended up having to charge
a price for the book that
was basically asking
all of my friends
to buy my book as a favor
to me, which I really
didn't like that dynamic.
Then they feel bad
because they don't
want to spend $13 on
a 170-page humor book.
So I abandoned them when I heard
of CreateSpace because they're
much lower cost.
I didn't have to
charge that much.
I can basically get away
with the donut book is $4.95,
and then the humor books are
basically $6 and $7 each.
And I can do that because,
well, a) my royalties
are really low
because that's kind of
irrelevant in this whole thing.
But also that the cost of
them simply printing on demand
is so cheap.
In particular, the dynamic that
pushes the price up, especially
for Lulu.com-- this
is one of things--
is if they wanted to
put it into a channel
so that people would
actually buy it somewhere,
which I thought was kind of
a requirement for a book.
They basically need to
build in high enough price
because the retail place is
going to take half of that.
So it has to be high enough
that the place that's selling it
is taking half of it, and then
all of their cost and profit
are built into the rest.
With CreateSpace
you have the option
to only sell it through Amazon
and CreateSpace directly,
which is what I do.
And so then there's
basically no retail cost.
If I wanted it to be available
so that Barnes & Nobles could
actually sell these books in the
two stores that they have left,
then I would have to
basically double that price.
Then it would become
a $10, $12, $13 book
through CreateSpace as well.
So I opted not to
do that, and now
if people want to buy the
book they can go to Amazon.
It works for me.
ALON HALEVY: Then if
it were expensive,
people would have an
excuse not to buy it.
Now they're not buying it.
CHET HAASE: True.
Now I have to rationalize
that they just don't like me.
ALON HALEVY: Yeah.
CHET HAASE: OK, thanks.
Thanks for that.
Appreciate it.
I think I explained this thing.
Yeah, I did.
So here's some of the numbers
involved with print on demand.
So the first book
that I published,
it retails for $5.95.
I will occasionally see
it on sale in Amazon.
Sometimes it's $5.49,
sometimes it's $5.36.
I have no idea how
they set these prices.
They can't be based on volume
because these books don't
hit volumes.
But I think it's just whim.
So it retails for $5.95.
Out of that I get
a royalty of $0.68.
And then you can
go in their site
and basically say what if I
charge $6 for it, what if I
charge $5, and then
you can see how
that affects the royalty price.
I basically wanted to
pick a price that was a 95
price, because everybody does.
So basically $4.95, I think
I couldn't sell it that low.
And $6.95 was too much.
So $5.95, royalty of $0.68.
If I buy it directly from
CreateSpace it's $2.89.
This turns out to be a
pretty good thing, especially
in the world where it's
nice to give these gifts,
or sell them to people when
you go to coffee conventions
or whatever.
And then at that point, you can
buy them much cheaper in bulk
and then just distribute
them however you want.
The next book was a
little bit longer.
ALON HALEVY: The
problem with gift
is you don't want
to give somebody
a gift that cost you $6.95.
That's like saying--
CHET HAASE: Here's $7.
ALON HALEVY: Yeah.
So that's why-- so
somebody gave me advice
when I was pricing my book.
Make it expensive so if somebody
wants to buy it as a gift,
it's a nice gift.
It has nothing to do with
the book itself, right.
It's just about the price.
CHET HAASE: OK.
So I should jack the
price on my books.
ALON HALEVY: $25.
CHET HAASE: Thanks.
Thanks for that.
The next book was
more expensive.
All their prices are determined
by how thick is the book.
How many trees are they killing
every time they print one.
So the next book I had to
charge a little bit more
for because it was
a little bit larger.
So now it's $6.95 book.
I make a massive
royalty of $0.85.
I pay only $3.32 if I
want to buy them in bulk.
And then the donut
book is much cheaper.
It turns out if it's a
slim volume of poetry,
there's not many pages in it.
So it retails for $4.95.
Fairly pittance, $0.82 royalty.
So that's how that works out.
And then the author
price is $2.15.
All of that's a
really good thing,
except with CreateSpace you tend
to pay a bunch for shipping.
I think this is where they
make some of their money,
just basically charging
you an arm and a leg
when they ship you the book.
So you have to figure
that in, and you also
have to figure in the
cost of the donuts
in the corner of the room.
E books.
ALON HALEVY: Yeah.
I think a bunch
of futzing around.
So I put my book on
Kindle, iTunes, and Google
Play, thinking
Google Play would--
CHET HAASE: Be huge.
ALON HALEVY: Huge.
CHET HAASE: It would be huge.
ALON HALEVY: Yeah.
CHET HAASE: Yeah.
ALON HALEVY: And two of
these three platforms
generated sales.
AUDIENCE: Non-zero
sales you mean?
ALON HALEVY:
Non-zero sales, yes.
Thank you.
The truth is-- the truth
is that both of our books
are very gifty books.
You want to give them as a gift.
And so giving an
electronic book as a gift
still hasn't worked out yet.
And buying somebody an iPad just
in order to give them a $5 book
seems a little expensive.
So even though the print costs
of the Kindle are very low,
they haven't generated
that many sales,
compared to the massive sales--
CHET HAASE: Massive.
ALON HALEVY: It's
a safer version.
CHET HAASE: So I did the ebooks
for my first two books, not
the poetry book.
The poetry book,
like it's really
as much about the illustrations
as it is about the words.
And I like the way books
feel, and I like the way
the text flows around it.
And if you stick that on a
Kindle or a tablet or whatever,
it's going to
completely mess it up.
Like the images that I have
in my previous comedy books,
they're not as good
in e-form as they
are in the books themselves.
It doesn't matter there
because that's not really
what the book is about.
But when it's about
the illustrations,
I wanted it to be
preserved as is.
I may produce a
version that's just PDF
and is sort of pre-formatted
to get around that.
But in the meantime, I figure
this is not really a market
I care about.
But I did bother to do ebooks
for the previous two comedy
books.
And my experience was I
didn't do the Apple approach.
I didn't put these
things out on iBooks.
Kind of time thing--
I didn't really
feel like spending
the time doing that.
Kindle, they made
the process easy.
Basically, you can
go Word to HTML.
You futz around
a little bit, you
see how it looks on
these virtual devices,
these emulators that
they have, and then
you edit the HTML directly
to sort of shoehorn it
into what they need,
and then you're done.
It's really cool.
So then I did the same
thing for Google Play Book,
so I used Word and then I
output the HTML into Word.
Turns out that's not as easy.
You upload this thing.
You say, OK, here's my
HTML file that Kindle
was happy with, how about you?
And it says nope,
there's errors.
What errors exactly?
They didn't really
want to tell you that.
So then you can go to external
validators and you can say,
well, here's a
whole bunch of XML.
Why don't you
validate this for me,
and it comes back with like
700 errors on this file
that Word produced.
Things like improperly
nested HTML tags.
It turns out that
Kindle, I think,
is basically much more
forgiving of errors in HTML.
So I don't blame
Google Play Books
for not accepting the
HTML because it was crap.
Because Word was doing
a very bad job of that.
However--
ALON HALEVY: You're
blaming Word.
CHET HAASE: I am blaming
Word for having horrible
[INAUDIBLE].
ALON HALEVY: Finally you
have someone to blame.
CHET HAASE: [INAUDIBLE] about
web formats, I don't know.
But it would be nice if they
were a little more forgiving.
What I ended up having to
do with Google Play Books
was rewrite it in HTML.
I took all of the text
from each of these books
and I just put it
directly in some--
I think I used Dreamweaver.
And then there's another
program you can use.
I used Calibre.
Didn't you use Calibre as well?
ALON HALEVY: Um-mmm.
CHET HAASE: And that
turns it from HTML
into an epub format,
which is basically
an XML wrapper around HTML.
And it worked.
It just took a few more
weekends to get it there.
And then Google Play Books
was happy enough with it.
And it looks
reasonably good there.
Again, I probably
wouldn't do that
with a graphically-rich
book like this one.
It just doesn't make sense.
One of the reasons
to do ebooks is,
obviously, some
people prefer that.
I do get-- especially a lot of
the followers that I have on G+
are really into their devices,
and so they wanted these things
available in ebook form.
OK, that's nice for them.
Also, it's better for royalties
because there's nothing
being printed so the costs are
much lower for the publisher.
So with both of
my comedy books I
went through Kindle
Direct Publishing,
which I believe
is owned by Amazon
or at least
affiliated with them.
I can charge as low
as $3 for this book
and I'm making $2 back in
royalties which is pretty good.
I think with one of my books
I charged $1.99 because, hey,
why not?
So it's almost free
money, but then the market
is not as good for these
books is what I found.
So not as many sales.
Also the sales that
you're getting,
like the dynamics of where
people buy from is interesting.
Like you found very
little from the Play
Books when you published there.
I found more on Play Books
than I did for Kindle
because a lot of the people
that follow me on social media
are clearly in the Google camp.
So they're following me
on G+, they're getting
their information through there,
they're obviously comfortable
buying on Google Play Store,
so there was more of a shift
toward Play Store sales
instead of Kindle sales.
ALON HALEVY: Yeah,
see I have a life.
So--
CHET HAASE: What is this
thing you speak of, life?
ALON HALEVY: I don't-- yeah.
CHET HAASE: OK, marketing.
What do we do about marketing?
Go.
ALON HALEVY: Oh, marketing.
Yeah, so I was the chief
marketing officer of my book.
AUDIENCE: Well done.
ALON HALEVY: Thank you.
I go to coffee
conferences because I
get a lot of free
coffee, and I get
to meet a lot of interesting fun
people from all over the world.
So there I did a
bunch of marketing.
There was a bunch
of coffee media
that I managed to get
covered by all of them.
I'm on a couple of top
10 lists for niches that
don't have 10 books in them.
But it went well.
There are a bunch of good
articles about my book
that came out.
I usually, whenever I go
and give a talk sometime,
I will add another
talk about coffee,
like around dinner or
something like that,
if the hosts are interested.
I actually contributed
books to the NPR fund drive.
CHET HAASE: How'd that work?
ALON HALEVY: How did that work?
I went to a party
and I met this guy
whose name I forget right now.
He runs the NPR fund drive every
year, every quarter-- sorry.
And we started talking,
and he said why don't you
contribute a bunch of books?
We'll talk about
your book on NPR.
And I'm like, sure.
So that happened.
I actually went to a bunch of
local bookstores and I sold.
I went to a bunch of
cafes, and actually my book
is selling in 10 countries or
something like that, in cafes.
So that was just one-on-one,
so this doesn't scale.
Mostly to people who-- cafes
owned by people I wrote about,
so they felt guilty
that they needed to buy.
And for some reason
I got hot in Japan,
because I wrote about one of
the most popular cafes there.
And the owner used my book
as an English textbook.
So people that used
to come to his shop
would love to read my book
because they would learn
about-- they were
interested in coffee anyway
and they wanted to learn
English, so by reading my book
they killed two birds
with one stone, literally.
CHET HAASE: Huh.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ALON HALEVY: Things
that you never
expect when you write a book.
CHET HAASE: On my book,
it's basically word of mouth
and it's social media.
My social media outlets
are basically a whole bunch
of followers on G+ and Twitter.
But they're in a specific niche.
They follow me
because they think I'm
going to talk about Android.
[LAUGHTER]
ALON HALEVY: So they're
buying your book by mistake.
CHET HAASE: Or not,
as it turns out.
I keep hitting them with
comedy, and then eventually I'd
say, by the way,
here's some books.
Some of them buy it.
But other than
that, word of mouth
turns out not a real huge
way to market your books.
I think you need to do things
like go to these conferences.
You go and you give book talks.
This is what real authors do.
They go to bookstores,
they advertise this thing,
they give a talk.
It's a little bit harder
if your book is not
about a particular thing.
I think you have more luck if
you are trying to teach them
about coffee, if you're trying
to have a particular experience
that you're driving with
that, as opposed to, hey,
here's some funny essays.
ALON HALEVY: The other
thing, by the way,
is give a talk about your book
two weeks before Christmas.
That's what I did at Google
before when my book came out.
So then--
CHET HAASE: The gift thing.
ALON HALEVY: --then the gift
thing works really well.
CHET HAASE: So it turns out
that publishers I believe still
offer a service, which is
actually marketing your book.
Whether they do that
effectively or not,
it's certainly part of the
business that they're in.
So maybe that's something
that authors still
take advantage of.
OK, so why did we do this again?
To me, publishing a
book is a great way
of finishing a project.
I really enjoy writing.
What I found personally was that
I got much more into writing.
I had thought about writing
more for about 20 years,
and then when blogging
started, I actually
started posting things
online, and that actually
made me start writing instead
of talking about and thinking
about writing.
The idea that I could have
an idea, I could finish it,
I could sort of craft it
in away with that I would
like other people to see it.
I was happy enough
with the results
that I could have
other eyes on it
was a great experience for me
actually doing more writing
stuff that I was interested in.
So I started publishing those
blogs in jokes and videos
and whatever all
along, and then books
are sort of the ultimate
version of that.
It's a way of
finishing the project.
It's a way of saying
I did all this stuff,
and then I edited it, and
I crafted it into this form
that I'm really proud of.
Then you put it in a
book and you're done.
And you can point to and
say, that's what I did.
Maybe not a lot of
people know about it,
but if they're curious about
it you can sort of point
to this particular thing,
as opposed to saying,
gee, I'd really like to write
some more about something
someday.
So to me it's about
finishing the project.
It's about having this idea,
putting it all in somewhere
and packaging it up and
actually finishing it.
Turns out they're
also great gifts
that you can give to people
that don't expect it.
Did you get the same book twice?
ALON HALEVY: I may have.
I don't know.
CHET HAASE: We
don't want to know.
ALON HALEVY: Yeah, no.
CHET HAASE: And it's the best
thing that Alon ever did,
apparently.
ALON HALEVY: No.
It was a wonderful experience.
It actually-- I don't know.
A big part of my identity
is now tied to coffee.
You can talk to people
in this room who
have enjoyed having
a coffee guy around,
or find it a bit
overwhelming, or too much.
But yeah, no, it's been a
great exploration and project.
CHET HAASE: Oh, I wanted
to point out, too,
the book that I've
been reading here.
This as one weird thing
about print on demand
is George ordered some
books, and one of them
came in this bizarre format.
The actual book
is about this big,
and they cut this from a
different size piece of paper.
It was the strangest thing.
So a little
non-deterministic sometimes
in how they print these things.
ALON HALEVY: Yeah, see,
these are the random things
that happen to you when you
write a book about coffee.
So this is a coffee
farmer from Brazil sitting
in a cafe in San Francisco
holding up my book,
being tagged on
Facebook for doing that,
and I had nothing
to do with this.
It just-- and these
things happen.
CHET HAASE: Random
stranger sucking up to you.
ALON HALEVY: A random
stranger-- yeah, they're not-- I
mean I don't know
what he's doing.
CHET HAASE: This is right before
he winged it at the cameraman.
So I wanted to end
on a serious note.
"When there is a donut,
there's nothing wrong at all.
Life could be ruined,
people could die,
nations could crater and fall.
But if there's a donut,
just one single donut,
then everything's
good as can be.
I open my mouth and suck it
all in an I am a happier me."
"Some people might find
me vapid, my philosophy
lacking and sad, but when I
taste the warm sugar and fat,
I figure it can't be that bad."
"Everyone has
their own weakness,
their own special
things they adore.
For some it's true love or power
or clothing or shopping all day
at the store.
For others it might be
fun gadgets or video
games played all day long.
And who am I to
judge these pursuits
or tell everyone
that they're wrong?"
But meanwhile, I
just need donuts.
In fact, I'll just
have that one.
And then when I'm done
with it I'll have another.
This time a cinnamon bun."
"So let all the
government's fail,
and storms break the
Earth's crust apart.
As long as I have
my one single donut,
I'll also have joy in my heart."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I don't know if
we have questions
from this rather contentious
and controversial topic,
but we're happy
to field them now.
AUDIENCE: Don't always
do marketing for you.
Apparently they only do that for
you if you are already famous
or if they have some reason
to think that your book is
going to be famous.
But my friend who's
been published
by Random Penguin and some
other famous publisher--
ALON HALEVY: It's Random
House and Penguin.
AUDIENCE: Well,
they've joined forces,
so now they're Random Penguin.
ALON HALEVY: OK,
Random [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Well,
I don't know what
they're calling themselves.
Anyway, she's had to do
all of her own marketing
and talk to the bookstore owners
to get them to carry her book.
ALON HALEVY: But don't they
do enough marketing just
to cover their costs?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, they do
enough to cover their costs,
and they do enough to get
into some major bookstores.
They do do that, yes.
But basically, her books
have been a failure.
You should buy them.
CHET HAASE: And they do
at least the channels.
Like part of the dynamic
that I figured out
is, wow, to get
into these channels
so that Barnes & Nobles could
actually buy this thing,
I need to charge this
much money, as opposed
to like the publisher has the
scale where they can publish it
at a lower cost and it'll
still be in the channel,
and that is going to be pushed
to all of the people that
buy from them.
There's some amount of
just busy work stuff
that they're doing beyond
the sheer marketing.
But yeah, at the end of the
day, your friends on a $10 book
might be making
$0.50 or something.
Yeah, it's a little hard.
I mean this is why my friend
in the publishing business
was pushing me, like no, no, no.
Do your own homework.
You can totally do this.
This is not something that
requires an advanced degree.
You figure out when the
review deadlines are.
You figure out what
the magazines are.
You get the addresses.
You send these things
out every quarter.
Like it's all very
straightforward.
But it turns out I have
a job that I would really
rather spend my time doing.
So yeah, where's the trade off?
AUDIENCE: So if you were doing
another book like the coffee
book, what will
you do differently?
ALON HALEVY: What
would I do differently?
I remain an eternal optimist.
I think that if I actually
would do more marketing
it would do better.
The other thing I
could do is actually
try to figure out what
people care about reading
and tailor it more to that.
The book right now
is, it's a bunch
of stories about
different coffee cultures
in different countries.
But it wasn't possible
for me to really test out
what people care about
reading in the coffee world.
And people in the
coffee world itself,
even though they bought a lot
of books, they don't read.
They drink coffee.
OK.
They read tweets.
But in general, I mean
books about food and drinks
don't do very well, which
is part of the reason
that publishers were
nice but not forthcoming.
So maybe I would write
a book about big data.
[INAUDIBLE]
So a coffee table
book should be bigger,
because most people-- yeah.
If I were to do it again, I
would do a very interactive--
something really out there,
like an interactive book that
enables you to--
AUDIENCE: Pop-up book.
A pop-up book.
ALON HALEVY: No,
no, like something
that you can put on
your iPad and you really
have an experience.
That you can-- I don't know--
that'll actually help you make
the coffee or--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHET HAASE: Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]